foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson and welcome to this film
independent presents q a for the new
film Bruiser by Miles Warren special
thanks to our lead sponsor HIPAA and our
virtual screenings partner Vision media
and now please welcome our moderator for
day for today's q a he's the VP and
executive editor at ND wire Mr Eric Cohn
hi thanks for having me I'm really
excited for this conversation today
obviously there's so much to dig into
with this film and Miles I thought
perhaps as a starting point you could
discuss uh just how personal it is to
you because you watch a film like this
and clearly you know it's a very
intimate story so what were you drawing
from in terms of your own experiences
and the world that you knew when you
were sort of coming up with the initial
the initial idea
yeah so so the answer to that's kind of
twofold I think the first the first kind
of most personal aspect of this movie is
is mostly kind of the way Darius acts
and reacts to things I think I think the
perspective
of me as a as a kid growing up I was I
was very kind of reactive sometimes I
kind of had these anger things and there
was a lot of door slamming and it was
you know just kind of became a problem
but I but it also was something that I
like as I got older I started to realize
um was something that was in me I guess
and I don't know so I put that into
Darius as the sort of coming-of-age
movie and the two father figures
something that's not like the idea of a
stepfather by the father isn't
necessarily personal to me but it was a
it was an idea of using them to kind of
chart this this kind of coming of age
story
um for Darius as he learns these kind of
lessons about the limitations of what
what he you know should and shouldn't do
and what it means to be a man what it
means to be young and black and on all
these sort of things that I think I had
kind of
dealt with um when I was younger the
second thing that that uh kind of led me
to this story was the idea of World Star
videos the idea of
um use like crazy fight videos that were
online were equal parts embarrassing and
scary and in equal parts embarrassing
and funny and also scary and terrifying
and embarrassing and and so there was
this kind of like insane feeling I would
feel like like you know middle schooler
with my friends watching usually black
and brown men fighting right in these
videos and it's almost in this very like
exploitative voyeuristic
um way that we would be laughing at it
and some people would be like what you
know freaking out
been scared by it and so I that that
kind of energy is something I wanted to
capture in a film
um the way the way an altercation
especially between two larger black men
can can can be used as a way to kind of
like mock or belittle
um kind of them in this kind of weird
interesting voyeuristic way and so I so
I started to kind of pair that with an
idea of a coming-of-age story of this
kid and what it would look like for if
the kid who looked up to these two
figures as Role Models
um was just off screen in the course of
like one of these World Star videos
being made you know and so that's where
that's kind of where the Genesis for the
story
um came for me it was those two things
my own personal experience as a kid
growing up doing with masculinity and
then also these World Star videos that I
found so pervasive in culture so yeah
sure in your in your case what was it
about the character reporter that you
found relatable I mean obviously he's a
very complicated guy and sort of likable
in certain ways and then obviously you
know very troubled in others so so what
was appealing to you about that
particular challenge
I just think in reference to Porter I
relate in every way so it was an
opportunity to really
just be myself on screen and really just
to get into space with someone like
miles man
for me it was meeting miles and reading
the piece and understanding his depth of
understanding of The Human Experience
really and it was just a beautiful
poetry
it was just beautiful so to have the
opportunity to jump into space with
someone like that champion someone like
that I really just watch someone like
that do their thing and watch them grow
throughout this process has been like
the most amazing feeling for me so yeah
and months can you tell me about uh
casting Jalen's character because
obviously you know it's not easy to get
somebody at that age who can act in such
a specific sort of role what was that
sort of audition process like
yeah so so that yeah that was a it was
tough to find that uh that character and
yeah it's it's you know I talked to a
lot of a lot of a lot of really talented
um younger actors
um Jalen specifically was really
interesting he came in really late
almost like a couple weeks before we
were shooting I still couldn't really
find someone who
um could kind of you know get the the
sincerity and the natural ease of a
child but also do some of these these
more heavy lifting kind of acting um
um you know things I needed I needed to
get and so
um Jalen kind of came in really late and
I had I had a great conversation with
him where where he was you know he's
very he's someone who's very very
professional he's like he's young but
like he is on it and it's really
incredible
um gift that he has so much so that I
would have to like say like you can you
can make some mistakes you know you can
be a kid
um and so we had it we had a um I just
talked to him I didn't really audition
him I just had a chat with him and I was
kind of looking for someone who just
reminded me of Darius and I think the
what he brought to the table
was something that I didn't know Darius
needed because Darius was written in the
script as you know skinnier kind of
built like me a little bit like skinnier
and and
um smaller right and and I was gonna try
and put him in contrast with these two
father figures and Jalen's not that you
know he's he's you know he's getting
older and he's hitting the gym and he's
still he's still a kid but he doesn't
act like one and I started to realize
how interesting that would be for the
character to have a kid who you can see
slowly the the the kind of the genes of
his biological father being Porter
obviously seeping into this kid as he
grows up and and seeing a little bit of
that in him and honestly either
obviously I already cast Trey and so
there was something like that Jalen did
or the way he acted that really reminded
me of Trey and I thought that was really
really interesting
um
and so all those things combined you
know we got to the got to a couple weeks
before shooting and and I finally
started working with Jalen and once I
started kind of you know seeing him do
the lines and the way he would talk
about the character and how much he
understood and how much it was him it
was kind of a no it was a no-brainer at
that point
um so yeah it was kind of a long process
and and got down to the wire but that
was kind of
once Jalen started um talking about the
character and how much and I realized I
could maybe change the character a
little bit to suit him I think that's
when it really clicked for all of us
what was it like for you to work with
Jalen and kind of figure out the the
chemistry that you wanted to come across
on the screen because it goes through
such an amazing Evolution during the
movie
you know like miles was saying man Jalen
is just a very impressive young man
he's had to
he's had to be a man his whole life so
he understands a lot about manhood and
so
to be able to jump into space again with
somebody who is that quality of spirit
that is that quality of talent and is
that advanced at that age it was just
very
it was refreshing because it reminded me
of myself and it also let me know
the quality of miles is understanding
again as well because he casted someone
who was so
close to my spirit for my son so uh it
was perfect
I wonder what was on your mind when you
were thinking about the kind of feel for
this movie because there's some really
potent themes that kind of come up about
Fathers and Sons and so forth but even
before we get to that you know the
images of the movie are telling us that
this is going to be a very sort of
almost like claustrophobic experience in
a way the four three aspect ratio some
of the shots that you use and so forth
so I'm wondering sort of how you thought
about you know how how much you wanted
to show us versus kind of telling us
what this movie is about because it's a
very subtle piece of Storytelling yeah
thanks um yeah I think
I know I I always wanted to be go as
simple as possible I knew I wouldn't
have enough days I knew I wouldn't have
enough time to do a lot of coverage so I
wanted to make this film as as simple
and as elegant and as formalist as
possible I think mostly because you know
the the the the first inspiration being
those World Star videos I think a lot of
those videos are really interesting
because you got one angle it's usually
from a wide
um and I think that's why they're so
comedic in a way because you know you
can't cut in you can't you can't come in
really close and see the the you know
Terror or the real horror of it you know
you just you know you cut into a wide
and usually when you cut to a wide it's
for comedic purposes and so and so I I
wanted to do something with the fighting
where you know we start in wides and we
hang there a little too long and then
and then uh suddenly I come in and I
come in really close and and that's when
you you it starts off maybe a little
funny and then or or not as serious then
once I come in I want people to feel
like oh this is actually really intense
and scary
um so that's what I was kind of going
for the fighting but I also like the
kind of voyeuristic approach to cinema
that some some like that you can get
with you know the four or three aspect
ratio
um like in the the weightlifting scene
where we just kind of hold on that and
and you're kind of stuck there until
Malcolm comes in I just I kind of like
the helplessness the helplessness
um feeling that the audience kind of
gets from just having to sit there with
that moment you know
um and so yeah and I took a lot from
um you know I love filmmakers like
Charles Burnett
um Killer killing of sheep is like one
of my favorite movies and to sleep with
anger is another one that like is very
much a kind of a direct reference of
this movie just like the idea of a
stranger coming into a house and kind of
starting to tear a family apart
um and you know the way the way he
shoots those movies or
I think really interesting and dynamic
and simple
um and then a lot of the other
influences are are you know the you know
ozu style Simplicity and and um
pavlovski like Eda and Cold War and
obviously pulse Traders whole take on on
transcendental Cinema and that kind of
stuff and I really have kind of fell
into that especially when the First
Reform came out and I the idea of of you
know using four three and and boxing
boxing and characters and being very
simple but also being okay with letting
moments just sit and letting them sit
for as long as they need to and and
letting to kind of slower everyday
moments
um sit in between pockets of energy you
know and the ending like I think a lot
of those movies I mean like the way ozu
and the end of you know
um late spring is like has this like
huge emotional kind of moment after a
movie that's been so kind of emotionally
muted that's kind of something I want to
do with Bruiser 2 where it's like like
you know there are some there's some
violence right and like Malcolm's punch
is like a little indication of what's to
come um but it's very you know it's very
there's a lot of softer moments too and
then it's slowly slowly builds into this
like insane ex like you know
Shakespearean operatic explosion of
violence that really gets you and so if
you sh I wanted to shoot everything
simply simplistically so when we get to
that ending it's it like shakes you and
you you grabs you in a way
all right so Trey did Miles make you
watch all of these movies that he's
talking about to understand what he was
trying to shoot
he had me watch a few movies not all of
these I actually uh had to tap in with
him after the fact to get a list of
films man because he's just he's an
encyclopedia and he really isn't it
I did have you watch I think I had I
sent you Badlands and maybe look at um
at Martin Sheen's character and then I
had what else did I have to watch I
think that was made the main one
um but I mainly sent stuff for for the
character right yeah so yeah
Badlands makes a lot of sense Trey what
was the what was the hardest thing for
you about uh portraying this character I
wonder about certainly when it comes to
some of the violence of the movie that
they're you know physically that looks
like it's hard to do but also you know
emotionally as well like can you bring
us into it a little bit I mean what was
the experience like for you to do those
scenes
uh the most difficult
thing to probably do is probably
definitely to take a couple slaps from
Shamir but uh emotionally again man
that's
that's what I love about our art form is
being able to this is therapy to me so
uh to have again someone like miles who
has the opportunity and the
understanding and the capability
to translate that depth of emotion into
the screen uh as an actor I have the
opportunity to be able to jump in that
space and express it it's uh it's
meditation for me you know what I mean
and were you able to sort of slip in and
out or did you feel like you were
basically bringing this guy home at
night
thank you
I mean that's always the case but it's
you know
again like that's why it's like you know
you lift weights you get sore so that's
that's what I like about
the practice so yes and no because again
I relate so much to Porter so
yeah and and so for for you miles I mean
how could you tell you were getting
these performances at the right pitch
that you needed them to I mean there's
you're sort of working with a
triangulation of you know different
kinds of energies the whole way through
so what was the process like there in
terms of figuring out the the level you
wanted so it wasn't say too melodramatic
too overplayed or whatever yeah
I mean it was to me it was just about
compartmentalizing each person in each
performance and just making sure that we
were all on the same page because yeah
because all of them are so different you
know
um and with with Trey I think the key
was just no like knowing that a lot of
the sky I think is in like you know a
lot of the back story and and the the
kind of Southern Gothic
idea of this character
I mean I saw a lot of it in in Trey so
that so that was kind of just like one
of those things where I could trust and
just be like you know this is you um go
for it and it I think it was brilliant
and with Shamir I think
um Shamir it was it was just like a
constant kind of back and forth of who
Malcolm is and and how to how to play it
so that's not his his Misfortune is not
too over the top and how to how to do it
so that he's you know it's like you can
mine some comedy and the idea of a
Malcolm but also make him realistic and
and have him feel heartfelt and and feel
for him because he's such a he's such a
controlling
um you know intense guy
um and so yeah I don't know I think I
think like it was just before the shoot
just making sure that everyone was on
the same page we knew exactly what we
were doing and by day one I think there
yeah there was nothing we at all kind of
knew exactly what everyone's role was as
performers and so everything clicked
really well and seeing trevante and
Shamir like facing off together for the
first time it was like incredible
because I think we'd all just locked in
exactly what these two men you know
needed to do
yeah and travate what was it like for
you to see this movie I mean it's one
thing I'm sure to be in the moment to
have the kind of the expectations of the
material in your head but to have some
some distance from it and watch it as a
complete work what was that like for you
man I was so proud man because it's like
I knew he was going to make that film
and so it was really
it was like I mean I you know I just met
myself I feel like you know it's like oh
my dog you know is that kind of feeling
and then also
you know I I you know personally I Did
It For My like also you know everything
else but emotionally like at the depths
of my soul it was for my son so to see
that I'm going to be able to show my son
this film in like 15 years and be like
yo man
this was your first birthday gift and my
dog made this for you with me you know
what I mean I all that to me just it
gives me a really good feeling you know
yeah miles I'm curious about that too I
mean when you were growing up did you
feel like that there was some sort of a
lack of representation for this kind of
situation and the kinds of stories that
you were seeing I mean there is a real
conversation obviously to be had about
you know are we are as young people
being exposed to you know the kinds of
stories that reflect the the worlds we
live in and have certain ideas that can
help us sort of grow into grow into it
yeah yeah I think I mean
you know Shamir said something
interesting at the Toronto Premiere was
like this is a rare movie about two
black fathers that very much are
fighting to be into someone's life and
so that's obviously playing off the kind
of black fatherhood cliche right and I
think that's something that um I was
definitely like interested in looking at
but I also think in general just I mean
yeah I mean I wanted to make this movie
because I I felt like there was a a
specific Gap in in cinema in Black
Cinema more specifically where you know
you can make a movie that is is about
you know very you know morally ambiguous
uh complex
you know real people
um that are there's you know there's no
villain in my eyes but some people do
see a villains and some people don't
um but I just wanted to make a movie
about black people that that was just
kind of a Rorschach test in a way of of
who you are as a person there's a lot of
people who are very malcolm-esque who
hate Porter and watch the movie in this
very different lens than I do where they
they are like so devastated by Malcolm's
downfall and there are people who are
very porter-esque who watch the movie
and are like I believe in second chances
and I and I wish that that they would
let Porter in and that you know they're
just bummed that it didn't work out and
and that's kind of what I wanted for for
this films to
a movie that like depending on what kind
of perspective you bring on it you'll
might have a very different experience
because it doesn't really tell you how
to feel
um and then there's a lot of people like
me for example who's like very rooted
and darius's perspective and and it's a
coming of age to me it's a coming-of-age
movie that I hadn't ever seen before and
that goes in places that I think are way
more intense and and crazy than I think
I'd ever seen especially with black
films and so yeah I kind of just wanted
to do all those things I wanted to show
give give kind of black people black
fathers
um anyone you know in the in the kind of
black Cinema going space a movie that
maybe they hadn't much thought they
wanted needed to see or had thought they
needed but are happy that exists
yeah and Trey obviously a lot of these
conversations came up around Moonlight
as well I'm wondering how that
experience kind of informed the way that
you look for certain kinds of roles and
and you know at this point I mean it's
like we're talking about six years ago
how much things might have changed since
then
I mean man that
that's informed everything about my
career really everything from the way
to how I move from
a creative standpoint to a business
standpoint
to uh
uh relational standpoint so
Moonlight directly more than anything
affected my choice with this because it
is such a soulful
Soul enriching experience man I always
look for that and always
try to mine my relationships
uh I guess to find and to relate to
people like that or who have that
quality of soulfulness and again miles
is someone who has that so uh you know
you try to
try to get cool and get tight with
people like that because it keeps it
good
yeah and Miles I mean just to throw it
back to you for a second on the
Moonlight question I mean how how much
of an impact did that movie have on you
since I know prior you know you had a
short film that this feature was based
on but it was just a couple years ago so
it's sort of in the aftermath of that
film's success
yeah I mean Moonlight is is like I mean
I think any young black filmmaker who
saw that film and saw what that film did
like can't not say it's an inspiration
right like it's it's it I think it well
it influences like a lot of films black
films that came after it
um
so and I think it's part honestly not
like it's it's probably one of the main
reasons I was able to get a movie like
this made you know in the aftermath of
kind of what Moonlight the the heights
that that movie was able to achieve you
know
um and so yeah it was a very direct
inspiration of mine and and yeah it kind
of helped I wrote this script version of
of the feature first and then actually
the the short kind of came as a proof of
concept and so the short
the short ended up being kind of like a
thematic paring down of what this movie
was and then that helped me kind of get
to this point with making the future
um but yeah the short also was a was
kind of inspired in the wake of
Moonlight and then and then used to
propel myself and into this kind of into
making this feature and getting it out
there
and trevante it's not often they don't
let actors at your level take a risk on
a first time future filmmaker so and
you've talked a lot about you know
seeing a lot of
um you know potential and miles and all
that but but I'm curious more broadly
about you know how how invaluable is it
for you to work with people at an early
stage of their career versus somebody
who you know maybe has a little bit more
experience
to be honest with you man
I don't really care about all that I
just met miles and he was a really
quality individual but from a business
standpoint
for an actor it's obviously like amazing
and you should always try to find the
new high person to keep walking on all
that stuff but I don't
I don't really move like that it was
really just
miles is incredible he's impressive you
know
so
yeah yeah so Miles where does this leave
you I mean
um you know people say the short film is
a calling card for the future you got
the short film then you got the feature
so where does this leave you kind of
creatively in terms of you know how you
want to keep building
yeah I think I mean I I'm someone that
um you know I'm lucky to to have this to
have those two you know films under my
belt and and to have this feature made
and now I kind of want to just keep
pushing on kind of the same sentiment
that I was trying with the with the
Bruiser feature in that I think there's
such a large gap of films
um that uh could you know center around
um black uh black characters and black
stories that I have not even come close
to seeing and
and so I want to continue to write
um and push to get things made that are
that are you know uh more
experimental or interesting or you know
exciting things that I don't think you
know would get made otherwise
um so really I just want to push to kind
of fill the gap of of black Cinema that
is there that you know the that is
calling for characters that are you know
fascinating and and uh morally complex
because I have so many ideas and so many
characters and so many different facets
of black culture and uh that I'm
interested in that I'm just like I just
want to keep doing as much of that as
possible so
Vante you took a producing credit this
year on your Hulu series obviously but
I'm curious if you're looking to work
more on the producing side of things to
support
um emerging voices
absolutely man that was the whole
that's the whole purpose man
that's the whole purpose so that's what
we're doing right now
actually I gotta uh ask some miles to
help out with something so when we get
off here I gotta talk to him
uh well miles before we wrap I mean it
if there are filmmakers who might be
listening to this conversation and
seeing somebody who's maybe a little bit
closer to their own experience because
you're recently out of school and so
forth and what is there anything that
you wish you were you understood more
about this part this process uh that
wasn't clear to you going into it
um
yeah
um I think making a feature film is a
very very very delicate especially the
first one it's a very delicate process
that has a lot of stops and starts and
it's a genuine Miracle to make a film
and I think I learned that you know
before obviously before I made this film
but as as
we were putting it together and it's
falling apart and putting it together I
realized like getting the thing made you
know with the people that will make it
great is the most important thing so I I
would say like don't rush to make
something that's not going to be as good
because once it's not good you know it's
not good forever you know
um the the kind of the the longevity of
a film is kind of remarkable
um and it's a little scary too I mean it
took me a while to be able to let go of
the the sound and color sessions of this
movie because I was I knew once I was
done it was done and it was going to
live forever and you can always go back
in I guess and Tinker but not really you
know it's it's the way the film is for
as long as I guess until until the
apocalypse and we'd lose all our data
right so so I would just say you know
for younger filmmakers the
the you know it feels feels like
sometimes you have to push and sometimes
you do you really have to push or push
to get something made but but also like
being patient and taking your time and
making sure that all the pieces are
there and it's something that you can
like live with and be a part of you and
a part of who you are as a person and an
artist forever then that's when it's
kind of the right time I think to
to do something like this so yeah that's
what I learned
to Javonte for another filmmaker with a
with a first feature is uh really
excited about it and once again on your
radar what's the best way for them to uh
make the case
Tula 67 entertainment bruh they'll find
us as we out there Instagram whatever
it's at man just reach out send us an
email okay ready
nobody makes phone calls anymore yeah
yeah just Instagram DMS Instagram baby
that's where it's at man slide in the DM
all right well thank you all for being
here congrats on the movie and uh good
luck with everything it's a lot of fun
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]